william julier avocat bonsoir m julier
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur air
différence voulez vous faire réagir tout
d'abord à ses propos pour vous la faire
un sort comparable à l' affaire dreyfus
peut-être oui peut-être non le monde a
changé la sphère dreyfus s'était tout de
même une autre configuration mais la
politique était à l'oeuvre à chaque fois
que la politique s'immisce dans les
affaires judiciaires et bien la justice
est en danger
je pense en effet que le parallèle peut
être fait ici il s'agit des états unis
et dans le monde tel qu'il est les etats
unis sont capables de mettre une
pression très importante sur d'autres
pays lorsqu'il s'agit de questions
d'extradition
justement c'est l'inquiétude que les
partisans de julian assage peuvent avoir
comme emmener un procès dans des
conditions sereines procès où il ya
autant de pression et évidemment des
pressions politiques
alors la grande bretagne est considéré
on dit toujours que la france est la
patrie des droits de l'homme je connais
bien la grande bretagne
j'ai la nationalité anglaise aux côtés
de la nationalité française les anglais
sont tout de même considéré comme
le pays peut-être dans lequel on
obtiendrait on obtiendra on peut obtenir
la plus grande protection lorsqu'il
s'agit défend de défense pardon des
droits et notamment dans des cas
d'extradition il y a des précédents en
angleterre sur des demandes
d'extradition des états unis
il y a deux dossiers qui ont été gagnés
par les avocats de la défense
un assez récemment c'est la sphère
laurie love et puis il y avait un
dossier du même type qui remontait à
quelques années et où les anglais ont
rejeté la demande d'extradition des
etats-unis notamment en considérant ces
dossiers aussi lié à des à king ou à des
intrusions dans les systèmes
informatiques de défense des américains
et où la justice anglaise a considéré
que les risques notamment d'atteinte à
l'intégrité physique des personnes
toutes les conditions de détention
auxquelles ces personnes seraient soumis
si elle était extradé ne serait pas
conforme à la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme et notamment à
l'article 3 de cette convention alors
c'est cocasse que vous nous dites quand
même parce que là il ya 117 médecins qui
ont pointé du doigt les conditions
terribles dans lesquels et seraient
détenus julian assange on parle de
torture psychologique est clairement les
autorités britanniques sont montrés du
doigt alors bon j'ai cru comprendre que
les conditions de détention de julian
assange avait été un peu assouplie qu'il
était sorti de l'isolément donc
manifestement le travail de contestation
énergique qui est suivi par ses avocats
portent un peu ses fruits
voilà il ya deux problématiques à la
problématique des conditions de
détention dans le pays en attendant que
la procédure se déroule et puis à la
problématique des conditions de
détention à laquelle la personne serait
soumis si elles étaient envoyés aux
états unis et je crois que si
aujourd'hui les avocats de julian
assange à juste titre s'inquiète et pas
que ses avocats son ouvrage à juste
titre s'inquiète de la dégradation de
son état de santé
je crois que l'inquiétude est encore
beaucoup plus forte quant à ce qui lui
arriverait s'ils étaient envoyés de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique
aujourd'hui vous avez confiance
justement en un procès
équitable et serein au royaume-uni
puisque il joue énormément et je me sa
vie un cent soixante quinze années de
prison clairement alors c'est sa vie
comme vous absolument comme vous le
disiez on est dans un dossier où il y a
un enjeu une pression politique
considérable on en parlera peut-être
dans une minute il y a voilà cette
notion aussi de la politique là qui
s'introduit directement dans le
processus judiciaire avec cette prise de
contact il y aurait eu qui a eu qu'il va
y avoir de nouveaux d'un sénateur
républicain avec la perspective
éventuellement d'un accord avec trump
sur des questions de divulgation non
divulgation des sources pour la faire de
de la fuite des emails pendant la
campagne présidentielle américaine air
pour nos téléspectateurs un avocat du
sang j'ai affirmé que donald trump
aurait offert de gracier le fondateur de
wikileaks il dédouane et la russie dans
la sphère du piratage du parti démocrate
la maison blanche elle dément
formellement
oui je connais certains les avocats
anglais julian assange sont des gens
extrêmement sérieux les informations ont
été données en pleine audience me semble
t'il et ont été considérées comme des
preuves admissible par le juge anglais
je ne peux pas imaginer une seconde que
ces informations ne soient pas sérieuse
n'ait pas été vérifiés et dans ce que je
comprends le washington post avait fait
en 2017 une enquête très approfondie qui
avait permis de confirmer qu'une
rencontre de 45 minutes entre donald
trump et ce députés aux sénateurs pardon
républicain s'était bien tenu
après la rencontre reconnu par ce
sénateur avec julian assange dans les
locaux de l'ambassade d'équateur à les
programmeurs on a une qui s'est dit mais
enfin trendy qui ne s'est quasiment pas
qui est sénateur qui lui a quasiment
jamais parlé une fois de plus on compte
que ce que dit donald trump est faux bon
enfin c'est un sujet un petit peu
annexes je termine répondre à la
question que vous m'avez posée je pense
en effet qu en angleterre le débat est
vif
je pense que c'est en effet un des
endroits où le débat peut se tenir et où
le débat
rester dans le cadre de la justice je
vous donnais ces deux autres exemples il
y à des cas où les anglais n'ont pas
extradé aux états unis
la bataille s'annonce rude sans doute
des deux côtés mais je pense que les
chances de ce qu'une vraie discussions
se tiennent avec une égalité des armes
dans la discussion est réel est
imprécise et peut-être dernier point le
contrairement à la france en angleterre
une fois qu'une décision judiciaire est
prise sur l'extradition
il n'est pas possible au pouvoir
politique de s'immiscer pour aller dans
un autre sens en france c'est une
extradition est décidée par le pouvoir
judiciaire
7 au premier ministre de prendre la
décision de finale d'extradition relève
d'un décret pris par le premier ministre
est donc le premier ministre peut
toujours décider de ne pas extrader si
la justice a dit de le faire en
angleterre c'était possible mais ça ne
l'est plus donc le dernier mot sera dit
par l'institution judiciaire et
l'angleterre cas évidemment où se
déroule ce procès mais il ya la france
qui joue un rôle un maître
dupond-moretti qui fait partie de la
défense internationale effectivement
l'idée au également qui a été formulée
d'une demande d'asile aux autorités
françaises
c'est bon signe ça on reconnaît maître
dupond moretti pour ses exploits
notamment au bénin il a tort c'est son
surnom c'est une bonne nouvelle selon
vous pour génial à 100 et je pense que
c'est intelligent de renforcer l'équipe
au plan européen
il a été dit
voilà tous leurs effets au niveau des
institutions internationales
cette idée de demander l'asile est
intéressante pour deux raisons
premièrement politiquement et eric
dupond-moretti de la rappeler la
constitution française c'est l'article
53-1 dit que les autorités de la
république ont toujours c'est
l'expression le pouvoir et bien
d'accorder l'asile à un étranger
persécuté en raison de son action en
faveur de la liberté
le seul exemple qu'on a c'est
l'ayatollah khomeini c'est giscard qui
avait accordé l'asile à l'ayatollah
comédie avant qu'il retourne en iran
donc eric dupond moretti a raison de
dire que c'est possible je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait d'autres précédents
je ne suis pas certain que le président
macron ira dans la même direction celle
qui avait été prise par giscard en tout
cas juridiquement ça existe et c'est une
piste qui me semble tout à fait
intéressante à voir ensuite comment ça
s'articule avec une procédure plus
classique éventuellement devant l'ofpra
qui est la juridiction en france qui
prend les décisions d'accorder l'asile
ou de ne pas le faire on verra vers où
tout cela va mais c'est une piste en
effet intéressante même si beaucoup en
tout cas m juliet d'avoir été avec nous